I mean that's even a problem for me
sometimes I mean every time been down
eight times and seemed very very very
little progress the biggest change that
I've seen is that from the first trip
the houses that were lying all over the
place have been cleaned up but that
really kind of just creates an illusion
of progress because someone who hasn't
been there before to see that will go to
the Lower Ninth Ward and say all you
know looks okay not knowing that there
should be 12 houses in the area that's
completely grass now you know at per
block so it you know it it is
demoralizing to see that three years
later very little has been done in these
neighborhoods but every means personally
every time I speak to a resident and out
and just like communicate with them on a
personal level it it changes me and it
gives me that motivation to keep going
and you know every time we rebuild a
house and get one more family home
that's really rejuvenating and what's
really been powerful has just been has
been the energy that's comes from the
group's when we get back to New York
City because you know when we're here
everybody wants to stay involved because
they realize that we're dealing with the
same issues in New Orleans that we are
in New York we just haven't had a
hurricane yet to expose those problems
in New York so you know everybody comes
to all you know the meetings and they
want to help and they want to stay
involved and you know one of our
probably biggest problem right now is
that we don't have enough things to do
to provide work for all the students
that want to stay involved you know
which is a great problem to have and you
know we're working on it and but it you
know it's a sign that we're doing
something right and you know people do
get you know do lose motivation in New
Orleans at times but usually day by day
when things go bad when we sit down in
the debrief you know even if it's half
the group is feeling like and half
the group is feeling great once we all
come together that energy is shared so
no one's ever in their own little bubble
of confusion and sorrow and despair or
whatever because they're always you know
brought back to the whole group and they
get to express those feelings and bounce
ideas off of other people and by the end
of every debrief like everybody is
uplifted to
much more powerful and more hopeful
placed by the end of every every meeting
that we have